yes and no it's it's a false choice
because you never know what's going to
work trying to guess what will please
the industry whether it's the indie
industry or the commercial industry is
almost impossible and trying to do that
is a fool's errand so in the end you
should just do what you want and see who
salutes it on the other hand it's
constantly a choice you're seduced by
wanting to write a very you know
blockbuster hit the kind of thing that
would have mass appeal and would be most
likely to be accepted by the studio's
because that's where most of the money
is and the biggest chance of getting a
thing produced but that's not
necessarily going to work and same with
going the indie route the indie market
is very particular you know if you if
you've got a story with a dysfunctional
family or drugs or some weird kind of
sexual relationship you know you're in
that's the indie world if you're just
trying to do a particularly intelligent
commercial studio film that's what I had
a manager who called those the tweeners
sort of between indie film and and
Hollywood films and it's a nobody wants
it it's going to be difficult to place
it's all comes down to luck but you know
if it's written skillfully it all comes
down to luck anyway that skillful thing
has a chance of making it and it might
never be noticed at all I'm constantly
trying to I'm constantly trying to
figure out how to be as commercial as
possible and still be original those are
movies that I like it's not just because
I'm trying to please some market but
those are the movies I most enjoy and so
that's what I'm trying to create and
it's not the other method that some
writers take is one for me one for them
you know okay this is my heart project
and I'm going to make it very true to
myself and consistent with my beliefs in
my artistic sensibilities
maybe someone will make it maybe someone
won't but I will feel good writing it
and then I'll finish that and then I'll
write a vampire movie right and so one
for me one for them and you can write a
screenplay quickly enough that that is a
acceptable way to go through your
professional life you can get through a
year after year like that
it does seem that that it's all about
style there's very little substance it's
telling the same old stories but with a
new kind of visual panache and that's
okay but that seems to it's like candy
and that seems to be the tendency not to
even attempt anything more ambitious
content wise but they're always trying
new ambitious things in terms of style
so that's kind of fun but I'm tired of
it and and kind of like many people
growing cynical about movies and would
like to see more more movies of
substance that have stories to tell that
affect my life in some way